demonstrationsfreiheit ist ein sehr
wichtiges grundrecht freie
meinungsäußerung und die möglichkeit der
soeben zusammen zu tun und da sollten
wir unbedingt so weit es geht möglich
machen aber man kann halt auch
demonstrieren mit abstand und mit maske
also das widerspricht sich ja nicht und
es gibt im klare auflagen wie für andere
das muss jemand dass er sagt sie ja auch
das muss dann hat jemand kontrollieren
also keiner will die demonstration
verbieten ja auch in der in berlin
dem muss und die er dann auch am ende am
ende aufgelöst hat man es doch
kontrollieren müssen
was heißt kontrollieren sie ist ja
aufgelöst worden weil sie die auflagen
nicht eingehalten hat nach stunden ja
wissen sie das ist doch auch für die
behörden überhaupt keine leichte
situation auch da übrigens
verhältnismäßig vorzugehen wollen sie
jetzt ein wasserwerfer auffahren weil
leute den mann also ist er total schwer
als stelle sich mal vor sie sind der
verantwortliche der das entscheidet das
auch in der abgewogenen
verhältnismäßigkeit zu machen was mich
vielmehr beschäftigt weil wir die bilder
gerade gesehen habe ich frage mich immer
was ist das
warum ja die maske nervt zum beispiel
nur weil die maske ist also das symbol
für alles die die maske nervt ich hätte
sie auch lieber öfter mal nicht tragen
müssen oder so klar gehe ich auch lieber
ins restaurant ohne als noch restaurants
geholfen hatten
klar gehe ich lieber in den bundestag
ohne mann ist überhaupt kein thema aber
die frage ist doch ist das wirklich so
eine große belastung